one of America's most liberal Governors
is declaring war on the Second Amendment
Gavin Newsom wants to change the
Constitution to curb your gun rights
what do we need this 28th Amendment for
and what California's gun death rate
today is 73 lower than Texas these
federal judges want to turn America into
Texas we cannot let that happen the 19th
Amendment to the Constitution that gave
women the right to vote it took 40 years
or so do you think that the 28th
Amendment if it's passed will it happen
in your lifetime I hope so if you don't
start will never happen at their best
all right Jessica uh there's no denying
that restricting the Second Amendment is
very popular with Democrat voters is
this his play to the White House
it definitely feels like a waiting in
the wings moment right everyone's
supporting Joe as it should be but he's
soaking up as much national attention as
possible but it is also something that
will not only energize voters but
something that a lot of people want when
you look at what he's going for and we
should know that the outside it's very
unlikely something like this could
happen who needs 33 other states to do
it but he's talking about things that
are popular with 90 of the population
like stricter background checks or
waiting periods before you can get your
guns and I think that it's an important
conversation to be having and I think
it's very smart and strategic obviously
of the California governor to be doing
it okay you know Katie
um I have a lot of friends in in Texas
and in southern states where kids grow
up with guns but it's interesting that
Newsome also is thinking about raising
the the age of possessing a gun from 18
to 21. as if an 18 year old isn't mature
enough especially if that kid grew up
using guns well they've also shot that
down in the courts already where they've
tried to raise the limit to 21 for both
handguns and rifles you can't do that
constitutionally you have to allow one
or the other Just Like You Can't Ban all
concealed carry you have to allow
constitutional carry or some kind of uh
concealed carry through a permitting
process you can't just ban it all right
um but in terms of who he's talking to
it is just a political statement it's
not happening you have to it's a
constitutional amendment it's not
something the president can do by
himself not to mention getting all the
states on board and he when I go to the
range I'm a minority meaning as a white
woman I'm a minority the majority of
people who are buying firearms in this
country are minorities and women and so
when it comes to the Second Amendment
they think it's a cut and dry 50 50
issue it's not and you have millions
more new gun owners in the past 10 years
they're not doing that because the
government's taking care of them they're
doing it because crime rates in their
cities are going through the roof and
they feel like they're being left behind
and allowing criminals to run the
streets and they don't want to be
victims and so I think he's talking to
the Tehran constituency and it's just
not realistic at all well it's
interesting that California had more gun
crime more total violent crime uh than
Florida and Texas where gun laws are
less strict I mean when we get into the
issue of you know acting like gun reform
is the solution to violent crime
he's like the guy that wears too much
cologne and he thinks the cologne smells
really good and everybody else is like
dude you're wearing too much cologne
he is
positioning himself to be Mr California
the rest of the country isn't in love
with California California is crazy he's
trying to check every box on the liberal
left to be their guy to run nationally
that's not going to play in swing States
that's not going to win you Ohio and
Florida North Carolina those moderate
states that you need to win nationally
You Look at California judge he's trying
to own homelessness drug addiction crime
he's shutting down power plants and now
he wants to get rid of the Second
Amendment he is going to leave
nationally so fast and run back to
California to its safe arms where he
belongs he could have run for president
maybe 10 years ago when California was
doing okay not anymore
Greg according to the Bureau of Justice
survey only seven percent of prisoners
arrested for a firearm used during their
offense purchase the gun legally
exactly I would like to introduce an
amendment that limits the use of hair
gel you imagine him he'd have to pry it
out of his cold dead hands he's like the
he's like the relative the young
relative that hangs is hanging out in
the hospice around Gramps is waiting for
him to choke on the strained peas he's
walking over every now and then he's
like gonna unplug the machines you need
you need a pillow yeah you need a pillow
oh I tripped I fell every you know he it
is pretty obvious what he's doing here
he's he's you know look he's trying to
get as much attention he's like a child
banging on pots here I'm over here guys
I'm over here guys he's also being
roundly humiliated every time he opens
his mouth because as you say everything
is political he says I want to arrest
DeSantis the reporter says okay you're
going to arrest the scientists because
no that's hyperbole it's like well you
said it so this is now guarantee you
this will be another thing that he will
say I didn't mean it was hyperbole
nobody could take him seriously anymore
because he doesn't even take himself
seriously and women hate that when you
say I didn't mean that yeah women really
don't like Gavin Newsom
that's true you're absolutely right
women like him they do have you seen him
sarcastic what all right Katie disagrees
all right everybody judge likes the way
he looks Sean Hannity will go one-on-one
with Gavin Newsom in a must-see
interview on Monday at 9 00 PM Eastern
no topic is off limits so don't miss it
and the fastest is coming up next yay hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now